all right top five games of 2015 number
five Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
I've been a huge metal gay fan - aided
and fed - pain just completely change
the formula and took it to such great
heights just the mechanics of exploring
the open world infiltrating bases and
the stealth system led to led to so many
awesome moments where you just be
sneaking around you know meticulously
marking enemies and all of a sudden one
thing would go wrong a truck would come
by a god you didn't mark would spot you
and everything would go to [ __ ] and
things going to [ __ ] in middle get
started with some of the best moments
I've had this year such tension just
like ripping at the controller and in
the same vein rocket lake is my number
four this isn't like one of the first
games that's ever made me like really
just like jump out of my seat just
yelling at my totally it's such a great
time playing multiplayer matches online
with strangers and with the GameSpot
crew every time I pick it up and play I
just feel such excitement and joy every
time I score the goal got a near-miss
minute epic save and you know even when
I lost I still had a really good time
with it that feeling of driving a car
and trying to make it hit a soccer ball
is so awkward but it's so satisfying
when you manage to do it right and the
fact that so many people are still
playing it really is testament to how
good that game is number three heroes of
the storm for PC I played a lot of dota
2 not the time for that anymore
so here's of the storm is what I call
dota 2 for adults because you only need
to put away 20 minutes for a match and
you know that in that 20 minutes you're
gonna have nothing but action you're
gonna have nothing but team fights all
the time you skill up really quickly any
low points that you do have will you
know quickly be washed away by the next
big moment or the next match so I have
no problem in putting away you know 20
minutes 40 minutes
you know however my afternoon a way to
just play a few matches appears of the
storm number two is her story her story
is one of the most sort of unique ways
to sort of engage with an explorer and a
narrative world in games like probably
ever the fact that your progress is
solely determined by
own willingness to sort of deep dive
within these sort of little video clips
and piece them together in your own mind
and sort of create the story for
yourself which can lead to you know
varying theories about what actually
happened it's so interesting so unique
and I like the fact that her story does
that the game doesn't assume that you're
an idiot and you need the story fed to
you by spoon the way that it takes the
story one way and then takes the story a
completely different direction and the
fact that that's not really manufactured
it's all on your terms because you're
controlling what goes where and when
things come up is just so clever
I just can't praise that game how do you
know that the game I definitely
something most hours into this year is
cities skylines which is the sim sea
that never was the is the ultimate city
bowling game when I was a kid I loved
Sim City and I loved games that sort of
set present-day reality and cities
skylines is the best city building game
ever the tool is so nice to use the
traffic in the public transport system
are amazing the way the citizens work
where they all you sort of have their
own homes and have a job and live and
die and move house and all that kind of
stuff and all of those systems working
together in a little ant farm is amazing
to see it creates problems you know in
your city that you can actually soul and
the modding support has been so great
there is basically an infinite amount of
new buildings assets Maps PD used like
it's the game that I don't think I'll
ever get sick of playing cities skylines
is just the pinnacle of the genre and
sub-genre that I really really love so I
can always see myself going back to play
like probably years from now and that's
why it's my game of the year
you